this is optimization it's the last thing
on the geometrical applications of
calculus you see why in a second
Coleco these are called maximum problems
I didn't mention that before you want to
know where's the highest thing where's
the lowest thing now there are three
broad categories here my arrows there
are three broad categories all max Mian
type problems let me tell you what they
are the first one and it's the example
I've got on the board right now a tall
tree the first one is just abstract
functions which have nothing to do with
anything in real life it's just X's and
Y's and I just want to find the biggest
y or the lowest Y that's all I'm after I
had struck functions abstract meaning it
has nothing to do with any context you
look at this there's no context I just
want to find some numbers the second
kind of problem is geometric well
situations I guess but an example would
be okay I've got a I could say I have a
1 meter cable okay I want me to cabled I
am going to cut this 1 meter cable into
two portions right and out of one
portion I am going to draw a square and
out of the other portion I'm going to
make a circle okay so this is like this
geometry here you see that right there's
a certain length of cable okay and my
question might be for instance what's
the maximum area I can get from both of
my shapes because obviously I can make
the squid bigger and that would be
smaller all right and there's gonna be a
different area there right where's the
sweet spot where can I get the greatest
area okay this is a geometric problem
and I'm looking for a maximum I'm trying
to optimize to get the most area okay so
this is a geometric type problem this is
not easy by the way but it's a classic
other things alike okay I put a a circle
and I have a triangle that's inscribed
in that circle what is the greatest area
of the triangle
I get how people make that like sex the
unit circles because I can draw a whole
bunch of different triangles that are
that inscribed in the circle which one
will give me the biggest area I'm going
for the maximum okay it's worth saying
maximum max and the problems are far
more frequent than minimum problems
because when you have a look at both of
these problems I'm free simple have a
look at this one I could get a triangle
with no area there is boring there's
nothing interesting there right Maxima
tend to be more frequent no there's no
reason why you can't find it long
because we have the applications of
different compactness to find comebacks
towards just different kinds of tender
points you would say it's a triangle
with height this something like okay
don't worry we'll get to those now
there's one other kind of category
abstract geometric and then they tend to
be like their real-world pose but they
almost all about rates okay so it's like
you want to travel somewhere or you want
to pour in water at such and such a
range what's the fastest you can do it
what's the slowest you can do it okay so
these are like your three overarching
categories the mechanics underneath it
are all the same
right it's differentiate find a turning
point taught me what kind of turning
point it is and then prove it
they're all gonna work through that but
the context looks very different and
questions can look very different even
though underneath they're all in the
same family a problem does that make
sense so we're just gonna start with on
one or two abstract examples okay
because that's where it starts often
it's easiest you don't have to worry
that these other concerns okay these are
kinds of like extra layers of complexity
on top of this so here's the question
that's it I've got a function you'll
notice I haven't domain this comes up
quite frequently maximum problems
because usually you have some kinds of
constraints such as my cable is only so
long you don't have an infinite amount
of cable okay
so you actually try to solve for a real
situation and because these are leaving
into these even though like this
function this domain is all relaxed okay
but they artificially imposed a
restricted domain on it to make things a
little more interesting into feed
towards here where there will be an
actual restriction there that's a part
of the question so simple here's a
function in this domain what's the max
what's the min that's it that's all you
have to find so let's tackle this
question now obviously we have calculus
to find out maximum turning points and
minimum Tony ones so that's the first
place we're going to begin let's get our
rivet in okay
I'm going to stay here it's a pretty
straight forward like so okay what am i
after what's the fine stationary points
I want to let B equal to zero therefore
I need to factorize the C that's why I
factorize are you afraid of me it's
because I'm going towards tankards okay
so I'm gonna take out my factor of three
what's the factorization three outside
the front it looks like minus one minus
three to be yeah is that okay so now I
can see where it was here not pause for
a second I usually would say fine
stationary points home in their nature
okay stationary points in themselves are
actually no use for finding a max or a
min what I really want is a turning
point we know that these ideas overlap
but if I find a stationary point and
it's a horizontal point inflection it's
no use to me okay so what I'm going to
say at this next point is potential
turning points right because I don't
know they're actually turning points yet
I haven't gone to the secondary review
and in fact I'm not planning to I'm
gonna say potential turning points occur
at and I just read off the values
because I factorize namely x equals one
or three don't now at this point I have
a bit of a choice okay you can sort of
go do you have your flow chart in here
right what I could do is I could find
the second derivative it's not hard to
find in this case I could find that what
is it max and one is a min like one of
them will be each okay and then I can
say well therefore here the conclusions
I'm going to draw except for the fact
that do you remember when we talked
about maxima minima we noticed that
there were two different kinds right we
said if you've got a maximum or a
minimum you look at your little
neighborhood right and you might be the
highest point but if you look further if
you look outside it's like no no no
there's plenty of places I can get
higher or lower than that so the
language we use for that was either
local or relative right that's like just
in this little spot there's no what this
question is asking it's asking what is
the maximum or minimum full-stop not
what's we write like in this little
pouch okay so therefore I actually need
to have a look at how far can I go like
this is corresponding to life what up
all the different
I can try so therefore these potential
turning points are not the only ones I
need to look at I also need to look at
the endpoints or they're also called
boundary valleys